it is always on it's like big bang
theory
you know it's always on both are great
that's why they're always on but i'm
just it's like you oh you missed the
episode just keep
hold tight
[Music]
hey what's up y'all to celebrate law and
order special victims units stars
marishka hargitay and christopher
maloney coming to the show
and both of them reuniting again on
screen for the first time in
years uh i'm going to react to the best
tweets and memes
about the iconic show see here we go i
can't remember what i
ate for breakfast law and order witness
oh yeah i recognized him
he came into the bar on may 2nd 2015 and
sat in the seventh chair
he had on blue jeans and black converse
ordered a martini three olives paid cash
that's amazing i can't remember what i
had for breakfast
it is funny oh laura you're funny
olivia benson in the 56th season of
[Laughter]
and the 50th 56th season of law order
svu
oh we just had him on the show buckshot
oh what's up buckshot oh my god that's
so funny he's a 91 year old cop
um has no plans to retire buckshot was
really cool y'all people are funny
in new york city these are members of an
elite squad known
as the special victims unit these are
their stories
dunkin donuts that's funny
i like that one i like that one i think
millennials
obsession with true crime directly stems
from law order svu being on at least one
channel on cable tv 24 hours a day
it is always on it's like big bang
theory
you know it's always on both are great
that's why they're always on but i'm
just it's like you oh you missed the
episode just keep
hold hold tight it's probably a and i
feel like there was one time we went to
florida for something for work
everyone was so tired and literally were
trapped in this room waiting all day for
this
and all we did was watch svu and we
watched like i feel like nine episodes
it was
and i'd have to leave and go do i say hi
to people and come back
and i'd be like what happened like and
that yeah
it's on all day when you're i
just this picture when you're a
dedicated detective that investigates
these vicious felonies
about your crush walks by
[Laughter]
what's he doing oh
he's like stretching out his arm and
he's just hanging out
can't talk right now doing hot girl
watches ten
episodes of law order s view in a row
hot girl
can tell what season you're watching by
my haircut
oh this is so funny i feel like i can
tell like when singles are out or what
tour it was by my hair color
when i figure out who done it 15 minutes
into a lawn order s
svu episode
i just love people they're funny
sometimes that was
awesome i cannot wait for this reunion
y'all gotta tune into the show
if you're cool and if you're not then
don't or just watch svu
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever